I heard my friend is really close by so
I want to go me a really quick through
she is how funny is that reese
witherspoon instagramming her personal
visit to her own star on the Walk of
Fame yesterday something that I asked
her about as she joined her wrinkle in
time co-stars Oprah and Mindy Kaling for
one epic girl power chat Meister and the
Walk of Fame is outside the front door
those hotels so right before we started
shooting ran out and they showed it yes
yes so she's showing dinner and then I
wait because a little dirty so I claim
that I'm walking on it they should be
walking around Savina I'll keep her like
get off free smoothers for the store
maybe it and they're like oh it is you
and I have to get their take on that
infamous bed if you care Photoshop fail
how many hands does over happy I mean I
seriously thought that she had three
hands as much as she does and you had
three legs well nobody wrote a funny
tweet the good well that's how Oprah
gets so much done
rhesus really was just that it was a
perfectly beautiful flesh tone that same
colors my dress yes well in their new
fantasy movie this threesomes wardrobe
is to die for
we heard a cry out in the universe
there's a live and we're here to help
you find them
who had the most hours in here and make
it I think it's me because I also had
the brows those little jeweled toned
brows
each one had to be put in one at a time
one at a time jeweled yes in one day one
of them fell off and it was like a
crystal is down very good redhead by the
way you should thankfulness to oh thanks
yeah the green lipstick she wears every
day though mmm that's a lie that I was
not a blonde
I was platinum gold pewter wow I see
just want to clarify that and at the end
of our interview that nice gals had
quite the surprise for me isn't this
your birthday though it is my birthday
well I just wanted to say
[Music]
thank you for interviewing us on your
birthday thanks for - no you're supposed
to be at home in your yeah it's old for
you come on more thing
singing - you and your birthday know I
love those three ladies that was so
sweet
[Music]